here's what would happen if bees went  extinct well first plants would start  dying because they're not getting  pollinated then our favorite herbivores  would be the next to go a lot of meat  and dairy products would go with them  and then combine severe food shortages  and soaring inflation with a growing  population of over 7 billion people  well it's not a pretty picture  corn wheat and rice are wind pollinated  crops so we'd still have food to eat if  the bees went extinct but having lost  most fruits and vegetables be prepared  to adopt a bland less nutritious diet  now it may not have to come to that in  certain parts of China humans have  started hand pollinating their crops  drone pollination and even robot  pollinators or other avenues to consider  however we'd be paying a lot more for  something Mother Nature now gives us for  free so